Korea's 17th presidential election is making headlines around the world!
If you look at all of the foreign media talking about Korean politics,...
...this should indicate that Korea is the center of attention.
Let's assume that tomorrow is the election day.
Which presidential candidate would you vote for?
To tell you the truth, I actually haven't decided yet.
But I have a list of qualifications that I thought the next president should have.
Being a great president means, I guess, being a good leader.
Now, a good leader should be a good message - oriented listener,...
...and a good communicator.
But the most important thing is whether or not...
...he or she practically delivers and keeps what he or she pledges.
What's your opinion?
What qualifications do you think make a strong candidate?
While I agree with your opinion,...
...I also look for other qualities that stand out:...
...a great person with a strong educational background,...
...and progressive development of his or her career.
Also, I think the candidate should have equal proficiency in two languages.
For instance, the new Prime Minister of Australia,...
...Kevin Rudd is perfectly fluent in English and Chinese.
It might not be a big deal,...
...but when an important figure like President or Prime Minister speaks two languages perfectly,...
...he can build strong relationships with neighboring countries.
That's my point of view.